ومع الان مباشره من اسطنبول مراسل كانت
حسين السيد حسين اهلا ومرحبا بك معنا حسين
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وجه الشكر
صباح اليوم الى الامم المتحده وكياف
لتمديد هذا الاتفاق
بعد اتصالات مستمره بالرئيس الروسي
والاوكراني والامين العام للامم المتحده
اردوغان تحدث عن ان 11 مليون طن من الحبوب
تم نقلها عبر اكثر من 500 سفينه منذ ان تم
توقيع هذا الاتفاق في تموز يوليو الماضي
وان هذا الاتفاق مهم وتمديد الاتفاق مهم
جدا من اجل ايصال هذه الحبوب الى الدول
الفقيره والى كل من يحتاج هذه الحبوب ولكن
بطبيعه الحال نتذكر ان روسيا اشترت بعد ان
تمديد الحبوب ان تمديد هذا الاتفاق مرتبط
بالسماح باطلاق شحنات الحبوب والاسمده
الروسيه وهو ما كانت تؤكد عليه تركيا
بطبيعه الحال تقول ان العالم بحاجه الى
الاسمده والحبوب الروسيه ايضا كما هو الحل
بالنسبه للحبوب الاخرانيه وبالتالي ان لم
يعلن الى الان تم السماح باطلاق شحنه
الحبوب الروسيه ضمن الاتفاق هذا ما سيكون
واضحا بطبيعه الحال خلال الايام المقبله
سيستمر العمل في مركز التنسيق المشتركون
في اسطنبول من خلال تفتيش السفن الداخلي
والخارجه رمضيق البسفور من البحر الاسود
وايضا السفن العائده الى السواحل والموانئ
الاوكرانيه من اجل همم تعبئه الحبوب
وتصديرها الى الدول التي ستتوجه اليها
شكرا لك يا حسين كنت معنا مباشره من
اسطنبول